here goes to a coma klaus-dieter yawn
and his wife martina are at home in Peru
these two German doctors have built a
hospital at the foot of the Andes in the
town of Goethe wasi hello
so do you need a tuxedo yeah
the owns have brought high-tech medical
facilities to the descendants of the
Incas
the own spent a long time searching for
a suitable location it had to be
somewhere where people couldn't afford
modern medicine and where there wasn't
already a hospital somewhere on the
margins of society where the people were
struggling to survive because the state
had forgotten them finally they decided
on the Peruvian town of Korra wasi it
lies on the Andean plateau at an
altitude of 22 half thousand meters on
the edge of the pan-american highway
that runs all the way from Alaska to
Tierra del Fuego he F&B a liberty mo we
found all the conditions here there's AB
poverty there's a good road which you
need for a hospital and at the same time
there wasn't any Hospital in the area so
we came to Cora wasi and quite frankly
my first impression when we arrived in
may 2003 was that it's ugly poverty is
not something beautiful I want is the
truth klaus-dieter ulan is a surgeon his
wife martina a pediatrician their
initial training was in Germany followed
by post grad courses at Harvard and Yale
from the outset they were fired with the
ideal of providing the poorest patients
with the very best medical attention
yeah instead of taking well-paid jobs in
Europe for the United States they put
their skills at the service of the
poverty-stricken quichua people of the
Andes where the city yet their decision
was inspired by their Christian faith
they dispensed with luxury homes and
expensive cars and found the meaning of
life in serving the poor one st yes it
como estás hola as this cansado bien
yeah but in topic minor foul and your
shoulder I met my wife at school in the
11th grade Thursday we were 17 and we
realized that we both wanted the same
thing to study medicine and then work
for the rest of our lives in a
developing country and achieve something
there I'd first believe my wife wanted
to become a pediatrician I decided to
become a surgeon didn't from my earliest
youth I dreamt of using my skills
talents and training to help people who
really needed it and that's what we do
here that's why this work is always
meaningful shabbat anglish matson the
fruit muy bien sempra muy bien is alpha
as move avoid CNT business important man
come to you reach your limits here the
situation is stressful you're always
confronted with poverty and neglect and
that's very challenging but I never
asked if the work makes sense because I
always feel I'm doing something very
meaningful and also kind of here so I
said well you know I don't know
the project demands a division of labor
and if she gets more some dramatic but
apart from that Martina yon runs the
hospital her husband Klaus dieter
travels the world six months of the year
procuring new sponsors and voluntary
staff despues us a thousand lira como
siempre you lien tuc seattle differences
distritos 18 esta loca me and Madonna's
cotton house is literally of course a
modern hospital is incredibly expensive
in any country Peru is no exception in
2004 we started giving lectures my wife
and I traveled around a lot we have told
the story of do specie jana in 14
countries and we have always said we
want to build this hospital trusting in
God to provide modern medical treatment
for the poor do you want to share this
vision and so far 40,000 people from
many countries have donated 11 and a
half million dollars and 180 companies
have donated equipment for many of them
it was the largest donation they'd ever
made sarsaparilla film kashish ticket 80
most of the patients are key to our
people descendants of the Incas Peru is
currently experiencing something of an
economic upturn but there's no evidence
of that in the mountain villages near
cordova see a fiscal there is a public
health system but the service is minimal
and it doesn't function well in all
parts of the country so the people come
to us with their physical ailments and
we help them on become yahuveh the name
of the hospital do specie Jana is a key
to a phrase meaning we trust in God
each morning a line of people forms at
the entrance the hospital has gained in
excellent reputation some of the
patients travel for days to get here he
does have a survey on me this man tells
us he's come from a great distance he
says he's been on the road for two days
we asked him where he comes from and he
tells us campesina into Arles Provence
he had to take two buses to get here he
says we wonder why he undertook such an
arduous journey the woman explains it's
because the treatment here is free her
whole body hurts she says when we ask
what makes this hospital so special
we're told that doctors here are very
good used to khanduri under six year old
son left home early in the morning to be
among the first patients at the clinic
the young mother suffers from back pain
three years ago some drunks attacked her
in the street and knocked her to the
ground since then she's had problems
with her spine
Parrinello salute this marine health is
very important to me for me and my son
stunt or without your health your
nothing I can't lift anything heavy or
walk normally I constantly have to watch
my spine and my hip if I were healed I
could do all the things I can't do now
en claro arellano re a las cosas que no
puedo hacer on i would like everything
to be like it was before lo que quieras
Roberts I can't do things as intensively
as I used to Labarre no Polonius air in
excess of las casas she can't lift
things and even walking as a problem she
was examined at a health center in her
village but they weren't able to help
now she's placing all her hope the
doctor is it do space agana esta viendo
esta cerca de Nicola um nah a neighbor
told her about the hospital founded by
the two Christian doctors to give
everyone the same chance of receiving
treatment appointment cards for the
coming week are issued on Saturdays when
there are too many people they have to
draw lots Nino tambien
say mama chic this is Tom Salem talk
about llamar por el otro lado super
pickin the moms have a better idea man
you vs diaz come with fam the stages my
list is your so let dr. matching a lack
of wisdom good so are many patients this
is the first medical examination in
their lives por la primera vez melodies
my yard meant in your captain Dearing me
I'm unfuck lavish had to I think some
were initially skeptical about what
these gringo doctors with the new
medicine would do many of them believe
deeply in their folk religion but I
think we've won them over simply with
the treatment itself Gilly I recomendado
have each okay camisa some force bodies
infamous the hospital is a
non-profit-making institution all the
patients are listened to and treated
costs are not the main issue here it's
about curing disease and easing the
patients suffering this kindness and
concern attracts more and more patients
nobody is sent away without being
examined your stuff is reassured it
Martina yon thinks she's discovered the
cause of the pain in her back she tells
you said that she needs an operation
after which she shouldn't have any more
trouble boy get in a city i think so
many people come here because they're
treated really well the doctors are very
kind and polite to the people they're
very attentive case in winter that's
really great sankari union con las
personas en linda
more than a hundred Peruvians are
employed at the hospital the doctors
from abroad all work on a voluntary
basis some of them have established a
group of donors back home who cover the
costs for their trips to Peru was it a
book as an ophthalmologist like many
others she gave up the prospect of a
well paid job in Germany to serve the
poor on the barren and in plateau ask
you something spooky Fayette under our I
particularly like the fact that we work
in a very nice team here and that we
provide very effective help to lots of
patients who have relatively few
resources if a patient can't see that
has an immense impact on his whole life
and we can operate for instance on
patients with cataracts afterwards they
can see much better and are usually
extremely grateful we can use surgery to
treat glaucoma which gradually leads to
blindness we can't restore the patient's
sight but we can often prevent the
person from becoming totally blind Sen
completa bleedin do specie Jana is one
of the best equipped hospitals in Peru
ophthalmologist also the book works with
state-of-the-art technology that's
essential for treating eye disorders
effectively the Kichwa people have come
to accept the high-tech medicine because
of the results it produces many of the
doctors from North America and Europe
who work here gladly renounce her
luxurious lifestyle in their private
lives but appreciate the
state-of-the-art technology on the job
nitin consume it you have the same
functions up on the screen and here on
the instrument is down on the foot
switch you can move the microscope in
all directions up down left right here
in the middle position and set the light
intensity here that's very important
because while you're sitting here during
the operation you can't keep adjusting
the instrument up here this patient
comes from LA convention in Cuzco
province that's far away about 12 hours
by bus and taxi he came with his son and
is staying here for a week we'll check
on him daily to make sure there's no
infection after the operation and that
his sight is improving the movie but the
doctors here don't rely solely on modern
technology we pray before every
operation because we know that we need
God's help and we also pray that the
patient will be calm and not have any
pain we've had some house and cottage
Matson yeah senior canteen we're going
to pray that God will help us Mary would
you pray thee same your canteen we're
going to pray now heavenly Lord we thank
you for this beautiful day we ask you to
help everyone here thank you Lord for
everything you have given us we ask you
Lord to bless this operation so that all
goes well and there are no complications
and that the patient gets better and
doesn't have any more problems in the
name of the Lord Jesus are men nothing
on the list is any anomalies in your
vessels I mean
there's no comprehensive health
insurance or general medical service in
Peru as there is in Europe the doctors
working here do so not just to achieve
medical results but to express their
Christian love and they receive a great
deal of love and returned from the
patient's well I don't perform miracles
I do the surgery God does the healing
but this is the 22nd time I have worked
overseas in various locations throughout
the world and it is because of gentlemen
like this I keep coming back manatee
propoganda the usual India catering
manager of paragory after vision copper
you hav them mr. Kennedy because his
vitac even I want to pass on the love of
God and communicate to people that God
has a great big heart above all for
those who are poor sick and in despair
and that he wants to reveal himself to
them and that's why I want to stay here
for many years
goleta see mattress oh just cus it the
pharmacy trace inspectors a la cocina
yeah yeah okay Bernard a gift of bananas
from the rain forest from the patients
we treat didn't come and put me on the
patients come and express their
gratitude they're simple people from the
rainforest to bring a crate of bananas
for the staff of the hospital sometimes
they knock on the doors of our houses
and want to give us fruit as a gift or
even qui guinea pigs it happens
regularly just [ __ ] to think music I
can show you her CT yes um she's a lady
who came in with cough and phlegm for
yearly had a sputum analysis in 2011 and
is resistant to basically every
antibiotic and a number of doctors spend
their vacations in kuta wasi and some
end up staying in the Peruvian Andes for
years I've been clutch expedited us what
that means in reality is that a doctor
who comes here for two years or four
years for fits between three and four
hundred thousand dollars he doesn't earn
that so his work here in this hospital
is an expression of his commitment an
expression of his faith what Christians
from many different churches and
congregations work here but they all
have the same idea that it's worth
making a great sacrifice for their faith
a personal financial sacrifice swing and
as early as Athena Taylor's offer
got a son
DSP see Jana is a mission hospital each
day begins with a short service
it's a religious avowal and part of the
hospital's daily routine the staff is
committed to serving their fellow humans
and they draw strength from their
Christian faith its mother [ __ ] 'this
dear patients just like these two jewish
men we are on the path of life each of
us has his own worries and troubles his
fears failures and unfulfilled hopes
everybody who is sitting in this church
at this moment has a mountain of
questions in his heart to which he
doesn't have any answers monton de
preguntas si respuestas cara una de
nosotros the chapel is full the service
is important to Klaus dieter and martina
gone in their work they're guided by
Christian values they also want to share
their faith with the key chua people
kept McCarthy gigaflops as a young man I
used to wonder if God exists I had a lot
of friends in school and at university
who were atheists and I asked myself is
this all there is to life doesn't always
end in tragedy at a graveside or in a
coffin or is there hope of something
after death and I decided that my life
would be a search for God I wanted to
know if there's hope is God real or just
a philosophical concept and when we
started the ospca onna it was clear in a
human perspective that it wouldn't work
you can't build a high-tech hospital
with all that involves with the most
modern equipment that costs hundreds of
thousands for very poor people it can't
be done but we said with God's blessing
if God is real then everything is
possible no quien te hace que eres de
esta gran noticia cristo vive todo lo
contrario klaus-dieter and martina yone
are convinced that this hospital could
not have been built without God the
project is financed and supported by
Christians and non-christians Catholics
and Protestants for Class D taeyeon it's
much more than the fulfillment of a
student's dreams
y por ESO no importa si nada but the
water DSP Siana it so do specie Anna
came into being and helped hundreds of
thousands of people became more than a
hospital a symbol of faith that gives
couraged Catholics and Protestants
Christians of all confessions they say
just a minute somehow the power of God
is revealed in the story of this
hospital that is full of miracles God
becomes visible in this story and if God
can build a modern hospital out of
nothing then the god of my life is
perhaps also real and worth praying to
what its appearance for the small
congregation of patients the Christians
around the altar don't only sing hymns
in Spanish but sometimes songs in
Quechua
I
after the service when the patients take
their seats in the waiting room they see
biblical movies and religious cartoons
on a large HD screen plus maybe welcome
boy you want a drink a la clinica dental
the hospital is attracting more and more
young people who want to work here most
of them come from Germany one of them is
elizabeti sack she works in the dental
laboratory there she makes false teeth
and assists the doctors many young
Christians like Elizabeth spend a
voluntary year of social service in
court awase others want to drop out of
the hectic competitive world and simply
help their fellow humans here in
Christian love dental technician
elizabeti sack had already spent weeks
even months abroad then she finally took
the plunge
I'm speaking um why she internet hot dog
I got on the internet and looked around
then I saw the DSP siyana website and
wrote to them and that's how it happened
the dental clinic was opened in 2010 and
Klaus wrote right back to say they would
be needing a dental technician who was
willing to stay on for a longer period
so here I am I think that God is at the
center of things here and people realize
that there's more to it than just work
and helping people anessa TVs has also
come to Peru seeking more than just
adventure the dental assistant organizes
the daily schedule in the clinic and
shares her faith with the patients
denied in hear from you so tender said
easily patent this is nisha the real
reason I'm here is to tell people about
Jesus that he loves them and he's not
just an old grandad sitting in heaven
he's in their everyday lives you can
sense and experience him he has all this
inhuman as oh of course teeth are
important but the soul is far more
important at four huh building continues
in court awase the entire complex with
the hospital and dental clinic an
apartment block and amphitheater for the
staff is being extended the owns have
bought a large plot of land nearby there
they're building a school with playing
fields as well as a chemistry and
physics lab that's another reason for
interested doctors to come to court
awase not only to provide medical
services in Peru but also an
infrastructure with schools and sports
facilities des hospitality and odious bc
on a hospital is fully functional in the
first five years we have treated 100,000
patients but we are still a long way
from our goal and we need more doctors
and nurses at the moment we are treating
100 to 150 patients a day in the various
departments of the hospital but we could
be treating three or four hundred
patients we need more mission doctors
who are prepared to work here to invest
the best years of their life of course
that means a big financial sacrifice my
dream is that in five years we'll have
20 doctors working here and that will be
treating not 20,000 patients but 50,000
or 70,000 and just as well as we are now
we are grateful for what's been achieved
but we still have lots of dreams I've
happening in the type of fela time
klaus-dieter and Martina yon are
confident that God will give growth to
the faith and love they have planted at
the foot of the Andes
Lee
the